[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk."
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
Our today's guest
is Ben Collins.
Ben is a freelance data
analyst, developer, visualizer
and founder of the
Collins School of Data.
He's also a Google
Developer expert.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ben, welcome to the show.
BEN COLLINS: Thank you, Minhaz.
Thank you for having me.
MINHAZ KAZI: Tell us a
little bit about yourself.
What got you interested in
spreadsheets and scripting
in the first place?
BEN COLLINS: Sure.
So after college, I went
into the finance world.
And obviously, my bread and
butter then is spreadsheets.
So I'm spending all day
with data in spreadsheets
with formulas, and
gradually, just
became more and more comfortable
with the formulas world.
And it's a little bit
like a rabbit hole.
The deeper you get into
it, the more you discover.
And so the formulas
became sort of,
let's find out how I can make
these formulas more efficient
and make my work better.
And then that led into the
world of scripting, and saying,
OK, this is really interesting.
How can I automate these
processes I'm doing
and extend power of the
spreadsheets in my work?
So that was my first
foray with spreadsheets,
and that was sort of, started
15 years ago, that journey,
I guess.
And then sort of
in 2010-ish, I came
across G Suite and the
Google Sheets world,
and made that step across into
G Suite and Google Sheets,
and found Apps Script
pretty soon after that.
So I could continue that journey
of learning and getting more
from my spreadsheets.
MINHAZ KAZI: So I have
to ask you this though,
VLOOKUP or INDEX MATCH?
BEN COLLINS: A good question.
And I've got feet in
both camps, I'd say,
because I think that the VLOOKUP
is a great one when you just
need to do something
quick and easy.
It works, it's great, as long
as you know how to use it.
And then the INDEX MATCH gives
you a lot more flexibility.
It seems to be the question
that divides the spreadsheet
world in two.
And I know that
in my old office,
we had camps in both,
advocates for both,
and there were pretty
fierce advocates for each.
But I think that I
would say learn both.
Go and do the VLOOKUP,
and then really, it's
not too difficult to jump
across and learn INDEX MATCH.
And that opens up tons
more opportunities
with what you can do with
the INDEX and the MATCH,
both separately and together.
MINHAZ KAZI: So let's
say I'm an analyst
and I don't know anything
about Apps Script.
Why is it important for me?
And how do I get started?
BEN COLLINS: Sure.
So let's say every week
you create a report,
and you apply the
same formatting,
you create the same chart, you
do a little bit of preparation
with your data, and
each week it's the same.
And you're sort of spending 15
minutes, half an hour, an hour,
doing this pretty
repetitive process.
Then that's a great
contender for automation.
And that's what scripts
allow you to do.
So with just a
few lines of code,
you can transform some data.
And then a few more lines of
code, you can create a chart.
And that's the power
of Apps Script.
You write that once, and then
each week, you can press a row
and it will do
those steps for you.
So a great way to
get started actually,
is to use the macro recorder.
And what that is, is a
built-in feature in the UI,
so in the actual
spreadsheet itself
where you can press
the big red button,
do your thing, which is
sort of add some formatting,
create the chart, process your
data, and then press stop.
And the macro
recorder turns that
into code in the
script editor, which
you can then just
go and run when
you want to repeat the action.
So that's a great
way to get started.
And then from there, you can
open up the script editor
and see exactly the code that
the macro recorder has created,
and you'll start to see, even
if you don't understand it
at first, you'll start
to recognize sections
where they perhaps, you'll
see some cell references.
And then you'll start to
understand a little bit
about how that
code is interacting
with the spreadsheets.
Another way is custom functions.
So custom functions
are a way for you
to write a little
bit of Apps Script
to do something
that's completely
unique to your workflow.
So you might create
a function that
uses Google Maps to work out
the distance between two points,
and you can just use
that function then just
in your Google Sheets, without
needing to keep rewriting code
or going to
external, to the maps
and doing that separately and
then copying and pasting it
back in sort of thing.
So it's a lot of time saving.
MINHAZ KAZI: Switching
gears, how did you
get started with Data Studio?
BEN COLLINS: So I
remember back in 2016,
I was doing a lot of
work with Google Sheets.
And then up pops onto
the radar this new tool
coming from Google that's
a business intelligence
tool for the self serve.
In other words,
something that you're
going to be able to use
yourself to create these
visualizations and reports.
And so I was just
super interested.
Because I'd worked in this
space for a long time now,
and so I'm always sort of
interested in new tools,
and especially ones
that will extend
the capabilities of what
I'm doing with the tools
I have right now.
And so I was super
interested, jumped on it
and got involved
with a beta program
and collaborated with
you on some feedback,
and wrote some blog posts,
recorded some videos,
and that's sort of how it all
sort of got started for me.
MINHAZ KAZI: One question
I often hear from folks,
is that you can always
build graphs and charts
in spreadsheets
and can share that.
What is the benefit of having
a dedicated business analytics
tool or reporting
tool like Data Studio?
BEN COLLINS: That's
a great question.
And I think one of the principle
benefits is, first of all,
it's very simple and easy to
use to create very professional
looking reports.
So with a spreadsheet,
it's a little bit more work
to make it look like
a report, a dashboard,
rather than a spreadsheet that
just has some charts in it.
So maybe that's important, so
that your stakeholders look
at the report and
take it a little more
seriously than just perhaps it's
a thrown together spreadsheet.
So it makes your professional
reports very easy to create.
Another huge benefit is,
it separates the data
from the visualization.
By having a dedicated
report that people
interact with, with the
data in a separate layer
that they can't touch.
It just make sure that that
data is nice and secure.
MINHAZ KAZI: You have
the unique capability
of looking at this from both
an analyst's point of view
and from a developer
point of view.
Thinking from that
angle, how do you
think Data Studio can be
beneficial to small and medium
businesses?
BEN COLLINS: What it does
is, it democratizes data.
It opens up the data
to so many more people.
And so both building with Data
Studio or being given a report
and interacting with
it and using a report,
are both very, very
intuitive and easy.
They have that same interface
as the G Suite tools,
so it sort of feels
familiar already.
And then building
the actual report
is really quick and really easy.
And so it really lowers that
barrier to entry for people
to go and explore
their own data.
And then also just
using those reports.
If a report is shared with you,
it gives you a lot of options
to interact with the
data, to drill down
into the data in
a very visual way.
MINHAZ KAZI: I love
the demo that you
built with the International
Space Station position,
so you could see the position
of ISS at any point of time,
like where it was.
Tell us a little bit about that.
How did you build that?
BEN COLLINS: Sure.
So it was right around the
time actually that Google
was introducing the
Community Connectors, which
are the connectors that you
can connect to third party
services with Data
Studio directly and pull
in that data from
another web service
into Data Studio, which
is like super cool.
I was excited about this.
And I was looking
around for some examples
to just try this
out, because there
was a couple of examples
on Google's websites,
which I tried.
And then I thought,
you know what?
I wonder if there's a
way to plot the position.
I'm always interested
in space stuff.
I follow the rocket launches
and that kind of stuff,
so I'm a bit of a space geek.
I searched around,
found an API that
publishes the position
in latitude and longitude
of the International
Space Station and thought,
let's see if we
can make this work.
And it was a great
first connector
to build, because the
authentication was,
there was no authentication, so
it was a nice simple connector.
Pull in that lat and long,
and plot it on the world map
in a nice dashboard that had
some touches, like a picture
and sort of a current date
and things just to make
it look a little more polished.
MINHAZ KAZI: You have built
a number of these connectors,
both as like open source,
and for your clients.
What does your
workflow look like when
you're trying to build a
connector for a new data set?
Where do we start?
What is your workflow?
BEN COLLINS: So
I would, I always
start by spending some
time with that service.
And it depends.
If it's a service that
I use myself, obviously,
I'd be familiar with it.
But if it's a client
that I'm working for
and it's their
service or a service
they use, then what
I like to do is,
make sure I go and
get a demo account,
spend some time
with the tool, so I
understand what the context is.
And I can start to
understand why would somebody
want that data in
Data Studio and what
are their plans to do with it.
I think it's very
important that you
have that context before
you just jump in and rush
to build the
connector, so that you
know when you bring that data
through that pipeline, where
it's going to end up and
what it might look like.
So I start with the tool, the
service, spend some time there.
Next thing is to go and find
any documentation about the API.
Spend time reading
that, see if there
are any tutorials or guides
to just have a look at
and understand.
And then what I do is, I open
up a Google Sheet and the script
editor and build a
connection to the API
from my Google Sheet
first, and then
start putting the data
into Google Sheets.
And the reason I do
that, is because I
don't need to worry then about
the Data Studio architecture
yet.
I can focus purely on the
connection to the API,
start getting some data back,
maybe check the authentication
and how that works.
And then start parsing
that data and making sure
that I've got the API piece all
built and sort of rock solid.
Then I can open up Data
Studio and, or rather
the Apps Script for Data
Studio, put in the boiler plate,
build the plumbing, and then
plug in the API piece finally.
And that's my
approach that rather
than trying to
sort of immediately
jump to Data Studio file
and build it in one go.
MINHAZ KAZI: So hopefully
some of our audience
would benefit from that.
Talking about the
audience, can you
share your favorite Data
Studio tip with them?
BEN COLLINS: Sure.
So I was thinking
about this a little bit
before I came in today,
and I was racking my brain
for something super
specific, maybe
a neat little unique
feature or something.
And then I sort of
realized that actually,
my top tip really is to
spend some time learning
about the best practices
for data visualization.
So knowing the best chart type
to use for the data you have.
How to make sure that
your dashboard is
as impactful as possible.
Because that will
have a bigger impact
than sort of focusing too much
on the tiny granular details,
if you really can make sure
that your data pops off the page
and gets that message across
as efficiently and effectively
as possible, then you'll
get maximum impact
from your dashboards.
MINHAZ KAZI: Ben, thanks
for being on the show.
BEN COLLINS: Thank
you very much, Minhaz.
MINHAZ KAZI: You can
check out Ben's blog
and his courses on his website.
Link is in the description.
For more Data
Studio content, make
sure to subscribe
to the GCP channel.
You can always visit our
website at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
Until next time, keep
building more awesome vis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]